hurricane durian hit the northwestern
part of the Bahamas is one of the most
powerful storms ever recorded in the
Atlantic wind gusts reached 350 km/h
Rouge ripped off and storm surges
flooded streets and homes this is the
direct canal that's right behind us and
you can see the waves are just raging as
if we're at sea before the storm hit
many residents decided to ignore
warnings according to the Red Cross more
than 13,000 homes have since been
destroyed communications are down on
some of the islands even as durian
lingers as a still deadly storm we are
in the midst of a historic tragedy in
parts of northern Bahamas mission and
focus now is search rescue and recovery
I ask for your prayers for those in
affected areas and for our first
responders it's expected durian will
remain over the Bahamas until at least
Tuesday morning before heading towards
the US as East Coast in Florida
mandatory evacuation orders are in place
as much of the state remains under
threat forecasters say the I of durian
should run parallel to the Florida coast
but authorities here are taking no
chances we are in a situation where the
storm is stalling very close to our
coast it is gonna make a movement and
the movement that it makes is gonna have
a lot of impact on Floridians and so
please listen to the instructions he the
instructions do what you need to do to
keep you and your family safe other
states too are preparing for the worst
as Dorian's path is projected to bring
it close to Georgia and the Carolinas
from its formation Dorian has been
unpredictable it may have slowed
slightly but the threat of landfall
storm surges and strong winds remains
the storm is still moving its massive I
will not take any chances with this one
you know it could continue to move in
directions that we're not thinking
dorian is still a powerful storm and the
u.s. is East Coast is bracing itself for
a days long of
and the predicted northern turn is the
best case scenario for the entire
eastern seaboard authorities here in
Florida a warning residents to watch
forecasts closely even the slightest
deviation could be deadly
the main focus for now is on the Bahamas
any rescue efforts are being hampered by
conditions on the ground but it seems
that widespread destruction and loss of
life is likely if durian sticks to its
predicted path millions may be spared
but no one here is taking any chances
and a Gallacher al Jazeera Port Saint
Lucie Florida